流動性是什麼
簡單來說
流動性就是錢的流動的規模和速度
也可以說是資本的動量
流動性好的標的
買賣雙方的交易活躍
買賣價差比較小
交易量比較大
資本流動的速度也非常的快
而流動性比較差的標的
買賣交易通常是不活躍的
很長時間才會有一筆交易
買賣的價差非常大
那麼資本在其中的流動速度
也是非常慢
為了說明這個概念
我來舉一個例子
比如說市場崩盤
表面上看市場崩盤
是因為價格快速下跌
但實質上來說
所有的崩盤都是因為流動性枯竭
導致的一個連鎖反應的結果
崩盤通常來說
是由於某一個重大的利空事件
引起的
比如說
2025年3月
美國總統川普對全世界
開打貿易戰
那麼面對這種突如其來的
並且是顯而易見的風險
市場上有一些這種先知先覺的資本
就會最先撤離市場
由此就產生了市場上的
最開始的大量賣壓
突如其來的大量賣壓
就打破了正常的這種供需關係
供需平衡
使得買盤不足
買盤不足
就會導致
引發價格的快速下跌
急跌又會導致後續的這些買家
逐漸的撤銷買單
那麼既然下價格會持續下跌
我不著急現在買
我等一等
將來也許有更好的價格
那麼這樣一來
這個市場的買盤
就快速的消失了
賣家為了儘快的成交
那就只能是不斷的
在更低的價格上面去尋找買單
這樣就進一步的
導致價格出現斷崖式的下跌
那麼買賣價差會進一步的拉大
這還沒完
價格繼續暴跌
對不對
價格的暴跌
會導致
大量的
使用槓桿的投資者
被催繳保證金
也就是所謂的margin call
甚至有一些小的券商
會直接強行平倉客戶的持倉
總而言之
市場去槓桿的過程
是不計代價的
而且這一些拋售的這些籌碼
在缺少買家的的一個市場中
將會進一步的
把價格推向一個極端
在這種狀況下面的強制平倉
首先會從一些
高風險的資產開始
那麼然後逐步的
蔓延到這些優質的資產
從而導致更大範圍的恐慌
和進一步的這種強制平倉
這就是崩盤的真相
它不是一個有序的退場
這樣的一個過程
它是所有人在同一個時間
朝著同一個狹窄的出口
的一種這種踩踏事件
在那個時候
資產的所謂的公允價值
所謂的內在價值
其實都不重要
唯一重要的是
這個時候我能不能夠脫離風險
儘快的兌換成現金
那麼價格的崩潰
本質上就是
我們說的這種流動性枯竭
導致的連鎖反應的最終的結果
那麼在災難當中
流動性好的標的
下跌的幅度相對小一些
如果要退出變現
也相對容易一些
而流動性比較差的標的
下跌的幅度通常是比較大的
買盤消失
甚至會出現你想賣都賣不掉的情況
甚至就是說
就算是賣掉
也是不得已要斷臂求生了
所以說到這裡
我想已經說明白了
流動性的重要性
這裡我再講一個小故事
2015年6月
中國A股崩盤
當時我在上海
為什麼崩盤
說實話
我已經記不得了
不過2014年到2015年
這一年當中
A股的大牛市
確實是積累了巨大的漲幅
我和我的一些朋友
都是盈利非常的豐厚了
所以說市場剛開始下跌的時候
我們其實是在第一時間
做了股指期貨
做了對沖的
其實一開始的時候
下跌還是可以接受的
我們基本上一股都沒賣
後來跌勢擴大
就導致中國的證監會介入
他先是要求這種公募基金公司
不許賣出股票
然後禁止股票的融券做空
最後是禁止股指期貨
賣空開倉
甚至提高期貨的保證金
這樣一來
基本上就是把股指期貨的
對沖的功能
就給閹割掉了
這是壓倒駱駝的
最後一根稻草了
那麼既然我們沒有辦法對沖
那就只能是賣出股票了
所以說
股指期貨閹割令一下來以後
就大量的私募基金
就不得不賣股求生了
那麼這就加劇了
整個市場的下跌
這個就控制不住了
那麼政府為了控制住局面
那麼甚至派遣警察
到私募基金抓人
那麼也有一些消息說
一些著名的投資人
頂不住這種壓力
跳樓自決的都有
也正是因為這樣的一個
突如其來的崩盤
那麼以及在崩盤過程當中
中國政府的一系列的一些亂象
或者說是
一些不可理喻的事情
那麼
包括中國政治經濟
都感覺像是在開倒車的感覺
所以那個時候我就下決心
清倉
換匯
移民出海
那麼我目前的狀況
除了房產以外
我的絕大多數的資產
都是放在美股市場
和美債市場裡面
因此為了保障我自己的資金的安全
那麼我對投資標的的流動性
是有比較高的要求的
那麼這裡我也分享幾個經驗之談
供大家參考
第一個
對於長期投資的標的
對於股票來說
我只投資美股
三大交易所上市的股票
確保我的投資標的
是在嚴格的監管之下的
我從來不交易場外交易所
也就是OTC市場的股票
第二個就是說
我投資的股票
市值不應該低於10億美元
最近三個月的日均成交額
不能低於5000萬美元
請注意這裡指的是成交額
不是成交量
這兩個意義你多思考
我相信你能理解
為什麼是成交額
不是成交量
這是不同的
那麼對於ETF來說
我要求ETF的資產規模
不低於100億美元
那麼最近三個月的日均成交額
不低於5000萬美元
市值
成交額
這兩個重要的指標
市值和成交額
是衡量流動性水平
最好的指標
市值越大的標的
那麼
100億的市值
和10億的市值
它能夠承載的資本的吞吐量
是不同的
市值越大的東西
那麼它能夠容納的資金也就越大
另外一個
成交額越大的標的
資本的流動性
流動速度就更快
那麼有一些股票日內交易
大概也就是幾十萬
上百萬美元
最多了
這樣的股票
基本上是沒有辦法
吸引長期投資者的
更不會有什麼大體量的
這種基金在裡面
這種小體量的股票
資金進出是非常困難的
但是
正是因為流動性不足
用很少的錢
就能夠撬動這隻股票
大幅上漲
這就使得
某些股價操縱行為
就有了可能性
這類股票
通常是日內交易者
最喜歡的品種
流動性較差的股票
買賣盤相對的稀疏
對吧
這也意味著
一旦出現大的買盤
大的賣盤
那麼股價就會被劇烈的推高
或者是劇烈的壓低
日內交易
正是要捕捉這種
由於買賣失衡
所導致的快速的價格波動
有時候幾分鐘之內
這個股票就可以大漲百分之之幾十
甚至翻幾倍
對不對
我以前也做過一些這種日內交易
最重要的日內交易指標
就是觀察相對成交量
比如說
一隻股票
它平時一天的成交量
大概也就是10萬股
或者說是10萬美元
但是某一天突然一開盤
第1個小時
就成交了10萬股
或者說是10萬美元
這說明
有熱錢進入了
做日內交易
就是要對這種
細微的價格的這種信號
要非常的敏感
要以最快的速度跟單進去
你就能吃到這一波漲幅
當然了
做這種交易
怎麼說呢
是一個雙刃劍
你有可能一分鐘之內
讓你賺個百分之幾十
那麼下一分鐘
也有可能讓你虧個百分之幾十
有時候明明是賺錢的
是浮盈的
但是因為流動性太差
平倉出局的時候
損失掉了
大部分收益
甚至搞不好還要虧損出局了
所以說絕大多數的日內交易
真正的交易
它的交易金額是不大的
他們的獲利
主要是靠很多個小筆的收入
叫積少成多
總之
日內交易
就是個體力活
這絕對不是一個叫什麼
賺最容易賺到的錢
這是很難賺到的錢
那麼今天我聊這個話題
主要是因為
近期有一些網友在提問的時候
給出的標的
我一看
這是明顯存在流動性風險的
所以說我想還是
做一個專題
告訴大家
流動性
到底是個什麼東西
好
就說這些
感謝收看
拜拜